bewerbung abschicken und ich habe mich
beworben was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video hey
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut heute ist wirklich ein sehr
produktiver tag ich habe heute einfach
schon zwei videos von mir selber fertig
geschnitten noch ein anderes cooles
projekt im angefangen zu planen was ich
euch irgendwann in den nächsten videos
berichten werde und ich habe die idee
für das heutige video einen schon länger
habe ich mir irgendwie noch nie
umgesetzt und ich bin auch wirklich
extrem gespannt ob das überhaupt sinn
macht oder wie weit das gehen wir da ihr
habt ihr wahrscheinlich am titel schon
gelesen es geht heute um das passt super
gut vor allem die sieht man sogar ich
habe mir diese ganze folge angeguckt
hilf mir mein freund mästet mich ich
muss ganz ehrlich sein ich stehe
manchmal morgens auch wenn ich noch kein
bock auf aufzustehen und auch noch nicht
aufstehen muss schaltet im fernsehen
gucken wir irgend so eine scheiße an und
ich kann da wirklich aus erfahrung
sprechen es wird immer schlimmer und den
leuten die sich jedes skripte ausdenken
den fallen immer bessere sachen einen
also jetzt nicht wortwörtlich nehmen
besser sondern einfach schlimmer und ich
hab mir gedacht das willst du auch noch
versuchen
wie schwierig ist es eigentlich zum
beispiel in sonne hilft mir folge zu
kommen
natürlich werde ich das jetzt falls mir
die chance gegeben wird nicht umsetzen
also so tief wenn ich auch noch nicht
gesungen aber man kennt ja diese stories
wo irgendwer der dann halt bei
schwiegertochter gesucht mitgespielt hat
auspackt und sagt was da alles fähig ist
die wir nicht geld man da eigentlich für
bekommen und wie man ausgenutzt wird ja
deswegen habe ich mir die frage gestellt
wie schwierig bzw
vielleicht wird es oder ist es halt in
so eine sendung zu rutschen dort
mitspielen zu können und vor allem wenn
ich mich dort bewerbe wie auch immer man
das tun muss kriege ich dann eine
antwort überhaupt oder das sollte sich
jetzt nicht dumm anhören aber in den
meisten formaten werden ja wirklich
auffällige personen gesucht die
irgendwelche äußerlichen auffälligkeiten
haben die vielleicht sogar eine leichte
geistige behinderung haben oder so
vielleicht grieche allein deswegen weil
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt ins schema
passen schon sofort keine antworten mehr
darauf oder so
lästiges wenn man eingibt sieht ev
bewerben kommt halt wirklich als erstes
erzählt bewerbungsaufruf also ich bleibe
ich das hier mal ein
wir sind jetzt auf der einen seite hat
auf der ganz normalen rtl seite da kann
man sich für alle wirklichen formate
bewerben der bachelor das mache ich
glaube ich raus so frau mache ich auch
einfach mal schwiegertochter gesucht und
adam sucht eva der rest ist für mich
finde ich noch keinen die tvh gut
vermisst schon also noch nicht so ganz
als sie dann haben wir aber auch noch
hilft mir da wollte ich mich auch
bewerben wobei ich hier meine chance
extrem hoch einstufen würde es wäre auch
super lieb von euch dass ihr nicht
irgendwie den leuten da schreibt dass
ich halt so ein video machen oder so
weil das soll am besten nicht auffliegen
wobei ich auch nicht davon ausgehen dass
irgendwer das zeigt dieses video sehen
wird oder mich kennen keine ahnung man
weiß ist ja nicht das ist auch nicht
immer direkt von rtl hier kann man zum
beispiel sehen das ist über die
produktionsfirma janus tv also diese
ganzen sendungen werden von
irgendwelchen produktionsfirmen
produziert und dann halt an rtl verkauft
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal
hier an mit hilf mir stelle kommt so auf
youtube neues hilf mir videos gemästet
seine freundin und dann bin ich einfach
da drin so wie lustig wäre das aber
werde ich natürlich nie machen am
villinger hilf mir jung pleite
verzweifelt suchen wir noch bewerbungen
ihre personenbezogenen daten werden nach
geltendem recht und mit dem mit der
größten sorgfalt auf basis modernster
natürlich nur standes und daten also ich
kann ja jetzt meine ganzen sachen
angeben das mache ich einfach mal
scheiße leute jetzt muss ich hier
eigentlich meine handynummer angeben ich
habe mir das gut überlegt ob ich das
mache nrw kein blabla weiter alter wie
viel dennoch man junge junge leute
schaut euch das mal an
blond größe 179 gewicht muss ich ihr ein
bild hochladen
was nehmen wir dann da das könnte man
nehmen ich nehme einfach mal hier dieses
bild dieses bild habe ich jetzt einmal
eingereicht das sieht doch echt süß ist
auch mein jetziges kanal wird könnt
gerne in die kommentare schreiben wie es
findet jetzt müssen wir schnell noch
folgende antworten geben hast du schon
mal ein wenn ja nein habe ich das schon
doch habe ich schon
nun ja ich war schon mal ich war schon
ich war schon bei zdf in dunja hayali
drin
man muss es ja auch irgendwie anpassen
dass die ob ich lust haben wann wurde
das ausgestrahlt das fand ich übrigens
richtig gemein das war ein sehr
gemeindebeitrag youtube verallgemeinern
so dass er echt schlecht dargestellt
dass man sagen ich glaube irgendwie
letztes jahr war das würdest du eine
kussszene spielen nein
würdest du auch der unterwäsche szenen
spielen jetzt kann ich sogar ein youtube
video von mir rein stellen aber das war
eigentlich ziemlich blöd wenn ich das
machen würde ich nehme einfach mal ein
video vom reise kanal bei sonst würden
die nachher auf der linken und dann
dieses video wir sehen das war ja nicht
ein anmeldeformular auch so wohl schon
gespeichert bewerbung abschicken
und ich habe mich beworben
jetzt machen wir das gleiche noch ganz
schnell hier auf dieser anderen seite
für das was hatten wir hier noch da ich
mich einfach mal für entweder jetzt der
bachelor oder adam sucht weil ich denke
ich mal für den bachelor eh keine
antwort bekommen aber ich glaube ich zu
jung bin dann sucht eva machen wir es
mal so ich habe hier oben mal angehen
ich möchte einen freund freundin
bewerben
hier muss ich jetzt hier gebe ich jetzt
etwas anders an als ich gebe es überall
geben eine e mail an da können sie mich
darüber kontaktieren meine handynummer
ist nur so ein bisschen zur es wieder
was wir uns noch erzählen meint freund
alex ist super talentiert findet die
sendung teil und bestimmt mit spielen
glaube ich hiermit bestätige ich dass
ich die datenschutzbestimmungen
blablabla muss man da kein bild
einreichen wenn wir warten jetzt mal ab
abschicken
ach so so jetzt laden wir noch ein bild
hoch nehmen einfach wieder das gleiche
ablauf
das dauert wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
wie es hier steht ops bitte haben sie
verständnis wenn dies einige zeit dauern
wir bemühen uns so schnell wie möglich
und wir bald an den bachelor auch noch
schnell hinterher
ich möchte ich möchte bachelor werden du
bist erfolgreich gut aussehend humorvoll
und hat alles was ein traummann zu
bieten hat dann begebt euch jetzt als
der bachelor ich kann mir schon diese
bewerbung vorstellen wo eine nach der
anderen abgelehnt wird
hallo ich bin so passt ich fahre
mercedes ich bin ja ich höre ich passt
perfekt als bachelor
das lasse ich jetzt erstmal wir haben
uns für adam sucht helfer beworben und
für hilf mir also eigentlich zwei
komplett verschiedene sachen wenn
irgendwas davon nicht kennt gibt es
einfach mal kurz bei youtube ein dann
seht ihr was das ist ja dann habe ich
mal dass ich eine antwort bekommen
irgendwann und dann gibt es natürlich
noch ein video zu den zu dem paar wird
einfach mal sagen wenn ihr die idee cool
findet und bock drauf habt lasst genau
jetzt mal nen fetten doch noch oben da
und wir sehen uns dann irgendwann wieder
also morgen kommt neues video aber zu
diesem teil keine ahnung wann es kommt
halt erstmal darauf warten bis die
antworten aber ich bin gespannt jackson
ist ab und wir sehen uns morgen ja
schöne grüße bis angela bachelor alex w